[Music]
let's talk about love
i love love you love love yeah who hates
love
um my mother
miserable people hate love misery loves
company
so they do love misery
there is love involved somehow all right
so this is
misery and negativity so this couple
here
um so the girl's name is kayla
she's 31 years old from massachusetts
and she had been wanting to find
love but because of this whole 20 20
pandemic like
it was really difficult to start dating
so she was just like i don't want to do
dating apps
i'm just like well if i'm just too good
for it i guess this year is not going to
be it for me
so uh so then that's when a
a friend a mutual friend named ben
arranged a
zoom call between her and this guy named
ryan
who's 34 or sorry 35 from oklahoma
and they ended up just doing like a zoom
meet up like hey
just two people meeting how you doing
i've done that yeah so then they
still get like dressed up like a first
date no but i went to like uh
i went somewhere to go on a date and i i
i paid for her coffee
oh cool wow wait how did you say you
weren't like you've been though like you
were demo
we zoomed in like facetime yeah and we
went on a date but we just she's in
canada and i can't
see her so you both were like let's go
to starbucks and you go to starbucks in
l.a she goes to starbucks in canada
that's what it was like yeah
she's like oh [ __ ] my starbucks is
closed i'm in a different time zone
no it's directly up oh that's good same
time yeah yeah that's smart
did you ask her did you ask her if she's
gonna invite you upstairs and he could
just take your phone and like are we
going upstairs right now oh that's
pretty good
like hey so is this over like or do you
wanna do a mutual masturbation
there we go that's hot sex right there
interesting so how did that go
great her phone died because we were
speaking for like three hours oh
that's how you know it went well did you
jizz on your phone then
uh prematurely uh charlie didn't get to
the fun part but are you still
talking to this chick or is it are you
oh she's cool i just can't see it i'll
probably be really shitty in person but
over face time it was cool what do you
mean he can't see anymore because her
phone died and she hasn't called him
back at all
she's still texting me with sorry my
phone's dead nope but why don't
i thought you really were like we're not
going to vibe but anyway so
for these for this couple these people
it was
an instant attraction um they
like the girl she said that as soon as i
saw him pop up on my screen i
immediately felt attracted to him wow
and um
and then so for him he said that same
thing instant attraction
and that he was on a huge high after
speaking to her for the first time oh i
like that feeling that's good
yeah that's why yeah mandates are
fun yeah that's a huge high after i'm
stupid
but yeah so in that in that first
conversation they got to know each other
and they got to know about each other
that they both love
traveling and like for her she had just
returned to the us
from living in bali for some time and
then for him he had taken a solo
trip around the world so traveling is
like very much
a part of their lives so um
they decided after like a few weeks of
talking
that they were fed up of being at home
and so they decided to go
to mexico together and so they got an
airbnb
hey [ __ ] like crazy
or is he short with math um was he short
was he short once you got there oh right
yeah there's a lot of different things
that would happen when you get there
yeah
smelly feet that's true well when they
they decided to go to mexico together it
was more in terms of like
we're just gonna go like travel buddies
we'll get a two-bedroom airbnb
and how a romantic dude
be like i can't wait to [ __ ] your brains
out me too
cause then that's just like high
expectations and they're trying to
actually find love
and so they're not trying to just [ __ ]
yeah well the best
is when you have expectations and it's
exceeded
that's even more intense because you go
i didn't know that it was going to
top this yeah and then you go oh my god
it's even better in person
you're speaking on joe's like exact life
right now
so you wouldn't have gotten uh airbnb
separate it's too separate no he's there
to [ __ ] because what he said
[ __ ] first and then love
i got us a warehouse baby
is when you're not expecting true love
and you're going there for a dirty ass
quickie yeah and then you go oh my god i
like you you're in the middle of
jackhammering her and you're like i like
see
it does work yeah yeah it's like what it
like
it's like i want this to be true love so
i'm gonna get separate apartments
shut the [ __ ] up you're there to [ __ ]
your brains out but you don't wanna
different values though like maybe that
works for you that worked for us no
you're how's your relationship going
right now it's [ __ ] amazing oh you
have one
yeah i got a couple nice there you go
true love
it's me food my my friend darian and i
my
yeah i got a toyota motorcycle i got a
motorcycle
you're up dude uh i have my ideas
i have uh darian no no i already said
that
okay nice i have uh enzo i have i have
leo
uh that i get to see every day and
they're so cute
and christina i'm full of love just keep
skipping
like oh what about anna christina yeah
i'm full of people
what about them those are my landlords
no they're the best no so anyway back to
this couple here
so they said that um
like obviously they went with the
intention of being travel buddies but
deep down they were
hoping for more um so you can't hope for
more
well hold on so living together would be
the ultimate test
and they already knew that there was
chemistry
and that they just really wanted to get
to know each other and really traveling
together and living together is like
a great test on a relationship i think
so [ __ ] yeah yeah
and so what they did is they flew to
cancun separately
and so she landed first and so she
uh he was saying that once they actually
met in the airbnb living room that
he remembers thinking that she had a
glowing energy
and that she was so sweet and thoughtful
because she bought him a dozen eggs and
some fruit for breakfast from the day
before since
she got there first and then so anyway
so they
the trip ended up being really nice and
then they went on a magical trip to isla
mujeres which is like uh
an island off of the coast of cancun
that's hot and so
they just had a great time but she says
like for her she was hesitant
she wasn't sure if ryan was the one for
her and
so they decided in a few days huh yeah
so then they decided to extend their
stay
i'm not sure exactly like 30 more days
to really solidify
i really need to know because i mean the
sex was good for three days but
unbelievable like would it stay this way
give me like 60 more days of it that
makes
they went on august 8th and then
they ended up staying until the end of
september but there was this one
like there was a week-long trip where
ryan went out on his own
and so they were separated for a whole
week and during that week she said that
she really
like her her feelings became clearer
clearer
and she wanted to give this relationship
a chance because she realized that she
really missed him and that she really
like
felt something with her way of doing it
oh smart way
yeah like detaching yourself and then
like making her be like [ __ ] yeah like
see how your life is without me
yeah true yeah you're calling him a
[ __ ] too you're a [ __ ] okay i'm gonna
leave you for a whole week [ __ ] and
then we'll talk
yeah in a random country [ __ ] yeah okay
so then when he returned
that's when they officially became a
couple on the beach in tulum where they
first had their date like the first day
and then that they witnessed the double
rainbow forming over the ocean so for
her
she interpreted as a sign that they
would go the distance
no that's a sign of precipitation in
there yeah it's very humid
that's not a sign for leprechauns coming
no
not a double rainbow it cancels out the
leprechaun oh so the leprechaun goes
this way and then goes down
he starts to appear and then he goes
away oh see and it's painful for him
well you could see a lot of those in
hawaii too so yeah so then the
relationship got put to the test over
the next few months because they
experienced noise from a nearby
construction the couple lives through
hold on
oh my god that is put together that's
why i was trying to do that one really
fast as soon as better
no but that's good that's good comedy
though that's good that's like someone
getting pissed at their latte order like
unrelenting noises do you have to be
this is what you're seeing privilege
right i know it's like you went oh my
god
we were the worst during a pandemic
you guys are going to sound like
[ __ ] when i tell you the rest of the
things no
but it's funny let's let us move on
let's keep going on this
i want to hear more i saw a double
rainbow they're holding hands [ __ ]
kissing swans flying i don't know
what people are dying underground of
iris the people that are probably dying
there saw the double rainbow two i know
they're like that's not true
you know so they went through three
hurricanes as well as a tropical storm
which brought floods and landslides well
that's where they went they had no
electricity no water and she also got
a parasitic like infection on her foot
to the point where she needed medication
and like so they went through some tough
times during the it wasn't just like a
crazy like fantasy world romantic
that's not touching times to me or like
getting even after the three typhoons
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] getting a bacterial
affection you're going to typhoon land
yeah it's like it's like you're like in
california you went through an
earthquake oh no it's like
so that's what kind of happens here they
were in the global pandemic
yeah right now during this yeah all of
this same
yeah if they got kidnapped by the cartel
and then his like half of his head got
cut off
that's really really bad pretty good and
she's like i'm really into next
so no i can't yeah stupid but anyway so
like that whole time like ryan was
really
thoughtful and affectionate the whole
time and he would get if you go
go pick up he would go pick up the
medicine for her and all this stuff
so then they actually came back to the
states
for to spend the holidays in boston with
her family yay
and like no rainbows over there their
parents are thrilled
but they said that this is a quote from
her she said but some of our friends
were concerned
you and ryan are great together but when
when this vacation is over you may
encounter some problems and when are you
going to come back to reality
where some of the things they said i
smiled because ryan and i ryan and i
have overcome quite a few obstacles we
are both committed to building a future
together i truly feel like i found my
person
you got some hater ass friends yeah
that's [ __ ] up i mean i hate people
that are like when are you gonna [ __ ]
settle down and be real
and it's like this is reality [ __ ]
well and they they did all this like
while they couldn't really go anywhere
or go out and [ __ ] yeah it was you know
how hard it is to experience
uh hurricanes together
what the [ __ ] the noise the crew oh no
there was a bulldozer across the street
and it woke us up
oh my god that tested our relationship
you're sounding really sarcastic right
now you know
have you done outside noise it's pretty
damn annoying dude it could [ __ ] make
a marriage crumble yes yeah dude tiff
one time there's a guy
in my neighborhood who was way too loud
it was like a year ago and tiff like
told him to turn down
his [ __ ] music because she actually
knew how to talk to him
oh you went to the door like no no she's
yelling out the window
yeah steve got brought out a bullhorn
everybody
like his own music blasting because this
dude he parks his car right next to
their window and he's like cleaning his
car but he blasts music
so loud so when they understood you he
was like oh why did you just tell me
yeah yeah yeah i'm like yelling i'm like
hey man come on pal you might be like
yeah he likes my music i'm gonna go
louder
yeah exactly you should probably just
bribe my model like yo bro i know i like
kendall jenner with that pepsi
commercial you know
i just want to go back to this why are
we celebrating their love
because it's a cute story during the
pennsylvania
make it all the way well i mean this is
recent
and we're just sharing the beginning of
their beautiful relationship oh they're
so brave
i love it how long how long have they
been together
they met in person in august
and they've been together ever since
apparently yo i want to be in tulum how
come the ones that cancun camp
i think anyone could fall in love if
you're in tulum anyone could fall in
love why does that feel so buff though
why not why are you so puffed he travels
[Laughter]
but yeah so they plan on going on more
trips even though we're
we're still in the pandemic but they're
trying to go to san diego lisbon
and costa rica the other reason we can't
go outside okay well they went to a
[ __ ]
cancun and look what happened hurricanes
and construction
oh hey construction construction is good
and built i'm glad that people are still
finding love during this crazy time
yeah right that's just like like i said
in the beginning of the
this episode let's talk about love
that's it
i like seeing dogs [ __ ] across the
street oh yeah
you